house just finished up hosting that
swearing-in ceremony
for judge amy coney barrett this was
after a 52-48
vote where the gop-controlled senate
voted to confirm her
the move fills the late justice ruth
bader ginsburg seton creates a 6-3
conservatory conservative i should say
majority on the high court
deborah alferon reports from capitol
hill
48 the nomination of amy coney barrett
of indiana
to be an associate justice of the
supreme court of the united states
is confirmed
after more than 30 hours of debate
senate lawmakers voted along party lines
to confirm amy coney barrett to the
supreme court
voting to confirm this nominee should
make
every single
senator proud the american people
their lives and rights and freedoms will
suffer the consequences
of this nomination for a generation
president trump tapped barrett to
replace the late justice ruth bader
ginsburg following her death
just 38 days ago we should not be voting
on this lifetime appointment while the
american people
themselves are in the middle of voting
so help you god
new york senator kirsten gillibrand was
among democrats
who pulled an all-nighter to protest the
final vote
warning the future of the affordable
care act is on the line
feeling the law in the midst of a global
pandemic results in even more chaos
and devastation vice president mike
pence was set to preside over the senate
for the final vote
but democrats urged him to reconsider
given the latest coronavirus outbreak at
the white house
the gop majority in the senate assured a
speedy confirmation of barrett before
next week's election
she's going onto the court because
that's where she deserves to be
the rules of the senate judiciary
committee are being twisted and turned
to create a political opportunity the 48
year old is expected to be seated in
time to hear some key cases
including one involving lgbtq rights on
november 4th
and another challenging the affordable
care act on november 10th
she'll also be on the bench to preside
over any cases that might arise from the
presidential election
deborah alfarone cbs news capitol hill